أعتقد أن المشي مع
حمالة صدر عالية التقنية على الخطافات عندما تكون في حالة حب
يشبه المشي بمسدس محشو
، وقد توصلت شركة ملابس يابانية يابانية
إلى فكرة عن حمالة صدر الحب الحقيقية ،
وهي الخوارزمية التقنية التي أعتقد أنها وراء
هذا  حمالة الصدر عالية التقنية هي أن جسمك
عندما تكون في حالة حب ينتج
هرمونات تسرع قلبك ، لذا فهم
يقولون إن كانت حمالة الصدر هذه تعرفك لفترة
كافية يمكنها معرفة ما إذا كنت في حالة حب ، فأنا
أعني أنك تقوم بالحسابات  هناك ، دعونا
نأمل ألا تقع في الحب في الشارع ،
يمكن أن تكون طالبًا جامعيًا في الفصل
ويمشي رجل لطيف جيدًا ماذا لو
كنت ستلتقي بوالدي صديقك
لأول مرة وكان لديك هذا
الحب المتدفق  بالنسبة إلى صديقك ،
فإن الشيء التالي الذي تعرفه أنك في الأساس
عاطل أمام والديه ، هذا أمر
سخيف ولكن الفكرة وراء ذلك ليست
سخيفة ما نراه هنا حقًا
هي فكرة اختراق الجسم ، لدينا
تقنية تتوسع خارج نطاقك
جهاز محمول ترى الناس يمشون
حول مع هذه العصابات على أذرعهم ،
ثم يخبرونك بعدد الخطوات التي
تمشي فيها ، إنها تأخذ هذا الاتجاه ويقولون
ماذا لو استخدمنا التكنولوجيا لفهم
أنفسنا بشكل أفضل الآن نفهم
أنفسنا بشكل أفضل لدرجة
أنني لست في مكان مثل صدريتنا  أعثر على بعض
الحب ، أعني أنني أشعر أنه من
المحتمل أن تتعرف على شخص ما
قليلاً قبل أن تعرف حمالة الصدر على خطافات ولكن
أعتقد أنه لا يمكنك إيقاف الحب الحقيقي
من الحدوث
[موسيقى]